si tiras un dado de 6 caras y un dado de
cuatro caras cuál es la probabilidad de
que ningún dado muestre un 1 la
cuadrícula de abajo muestra todos los
posibles resultados de tirar un dado de
seis caras inundado de cuatro caras
ahora el dado de seis caras ya lo
conocemos bien cierto es el dado típico
con el cual hemos jugado toda la vida
ahora se mira algo así y el resultado es
el que se muestra en la cara que queda
hacia arriba ahora tal vez no te sea tan
familiar el el dado de cuatro caras
cierto pero se mira algo así mira tiene
cuatro caras con la de abajo el
triángulo de abajo y el resultado será
justamente el número que caiga en la
cara de abajo ahora aquí tienes una
imagen de todos los posibles resultados
tenemos el dado de seis caras aquí esto
es lo que nos muestra la cara de arriba
tenemos el triángulo que representa al
lado de cuatro caras esta es la cara de
abajo ahora vamos a intentar responder
la pregunta porque se nos está dando nos
dan todos los posibles resultados de
tirar los dados así que cuál es la
probabilidad de que ningún dado muestra
uno veamos
a cuantos resultados tenemos en total
tenemos 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 6 lo cual
tiene sentido porque tenemos 6 posibles
para el lado de 6 caras y 4 posibles
para el lado de 4 caras ahora el total
sería 4 por 6 es igual a 24 24 posibles
resultados ahora cuántos cuantos de los
resultados cumplen no mostrar un 1
bueno pues ninguno de estos de esta fila
es cierto porque aquí tenemos el 1 de la
del lado de 4 caras y acá tenemos el 1
del lado de 6 caras así que ni de la
primera fila ni de la primera columna se
cumple lo que lo que lo que se nos pide
así que lo que sobra si lo está
cumpliendo todos estos si cumplen no
tener un 1 en ninguna cara entonces
vamos a contar tenemos 1 2 3 x 5 es el
total 3 x 5 es igual a 15 15 sobre 24
ahora vamos a simplificar esto vamos a
dividir el numerador y denominador entre
3 y obtenemos
en cinco octavos así que esto es
equivalente a cinco sobre ocho ese sería
la probabilidad de que ningún dado
muestre un 1 y bueno eso sería todo así
que terminamos